[Music]
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv values contes
this world are entrepreneurs we get no
value to haters run homie look what I
become I'm I'm the
one now now look our Our Guest today
we've been looking forward to this for a
while this is episode 33 it's the great
rosan bar of course uh we wish the
conditions were different so we can have
a different kind of a podcast but
there's a lot of things going on around
the world today with uh the the Israel
Palestine Hamas we'll cover that we'll
talk about that but let me properly
introduce Our Guest Rosanne bar uh
actress comedian writer producer who was
best known for her role in the
television sitcom Rosanne for which she
won an Emmy a Golden Globe award for
outstanding lead actress in a comedy
series she was also nominated for four
additional uh Emmy Awards for her work
and was nominated for seven Actor Guild
award and outstanding performance by a
female actor in a comedy series in
addition she won six People Choice
Awards three American Comedy Awards a
Kids Choice Award a glad award and
tvland an innovator award Ren was a
critical and comical Commercial Success
not I have to interrupt because the most
valuable thing I won was the Peabody for
television the Peabody for television
forgive me for not saying that Peabody
for television anyways she rocked she's
been rocking TV you know media for many
many years I think even at one point you
were ahead of Oprah Winfrey and when the
show came back the opening episode had
what 18 and A5 million viewership 28
million 28 million people to watch yeah
it was great to come back and be number
one twice it's great to have you on here
Rosen thank you so much you know from
from uh uh uh for you you know you it's
your life right for us we we watched you
all you know all these years so we grew
up watching you to us it's kind of like
you know rosanna's in the house you know
it's a different kind of relationship
the fan has with you than you have with
us so truly I've been looking forward to
having you on here well I really
appreciate that I I appreciate my fans
so much you know they've saved my life
hundreds of times so thank you all in
what way ju just uh you know it it's
been a difficult journey and uh and uh
you know you get knocked down a lot and
uh you know from the top but your fans
are just what help you hang on their uh
support and um
Love is what helps you hang on in in the
dark times let me ask you Rosanne is it
something where uh uh because there's
two uh lenses that I see you through I
see a lens where it's like you want to
bully me I'm going to stand up and you
keep fighting fighting fighting to who
your identity is who you are yeah but
you're at the same time you're not a
robot you're a human being it's painful
as well when you're going through it how
do you what is the internal battle for
you when you're going through those two
are you telling yourself you got this
Rosanne you've overcome tougher things
are you kind of like dude can these guys
just stop and let me just be a creative
comedian why are they doing this to me
well I do both I do both and uh yeah I
I I I I can't help but
compare what they have done to me and
what they don't do to at first it was
what they did to me compared to what
they didn't do to men comics who did you
know even more you know even more
egregious things than I did now I was
always a Target you know a Target
because I was a woman who first of all
because I was a woman and second of all
because I come from Working Class People
I don't have a degree I dropped out in
ninth grade and uh worked and uh they're
all very you know in Hollywood they're
all very proud of
their degrees and their education and
you know they they're very arrogant and
I think they were they were always
shocked that I a woman such as myself
was in the room with them and I wasn't
serving them
coffee or cleaning up you know their
mess and they were like oh my God
she actually is here and she actually
says things that people like
her uh listen to and they don't like
those people
either and they don't like the people
who listen to you or you no because they
don't view themselves as the working
class the person that maybe didn't get
the degree and didn't follow the system
of what you're supposed to do so you
know how is it the people that are not
part of the club winning type of mindset
yeah that's kind of it too and it's like
but the way my stuff works is I don't
know I was just born into the world like
that
uh when I hear no I I I never hear
no I hear oh
yeah that's it you know I'm going to I'm
going to show you I'm going to prove it
because that's my childhood in effect
you know you're not going to ever stop
me I'll stop when I'm dead and that'll
that'll be it when did you know you were
that person that that nobody can bully
you when did you get that feeling were
you bullied and then you eventually
stood up or was it it was a process of
being bull bullied always and you know
having a rough childhood and knowing
that well there was something deeper
though I've always had a great faith in
God and that's what it is it's like
always I say you know I have so many
times been like Daniel in the Lion's Den
and uh there was always a fourth guy in
there with me you know and it's that's
the the only reason I'm alive I always
had that to fall back on and it
always God always put his arms around me
and it wasn't
uh it was like
uh we can do it h and it wasn't just me
I knew I
was trying to represent for people like
me so I never saw it as
uh I was a big old star and I was my big
old fat ego and you know I always had
that it was for us that I was a
represented you know did you did you
think like in your mind were you
thinking where man better enjoy this
process cuz this shit's coming to an end
quick this doesn't last that long of a
time or you were like no I'm going for
the right this is going to last forever
what what when you were in it and I'm
talking when you're peeking yeah well
that was the hardest part is peeking
that that was really really the hardest
thing there there was a you know cuz
it's like oh God it was a whole other
world that I wasn't prepared for I don't
think anybody who gets the the that
level of Fame you're never prepared for
it and uh you know everything turns on
its head nothing nothing you ever
thought uh remains how how crazy was it
like for you know uh you you'll in life
they say there's levels right hey you
you're making six I'm finally making six
figures I'm 26 years old oh wow you walk
into a room real estate office and other
guy's making 1.2 million oh my goodness
I will never make you make 1.2 million
want walking to him guy just Clos a $10
million cash oh 10 million walk into him
it's 100 million oh my God walk into to
real estate mog3 billion it's like then
there is the one right because that's a
different you know you're famous in a
small little Club then you're famous at
your state then you're famous in a
region then you're famous in a country
then you're famous in the world then
you're number one in world you went to
number one it's not like you know you
were not one of you know how they say
she's one of the great ones she's one of
the No No you went to the Pinnacle right
yeah I was the highest
paid person ever on television that's
crazy to think I know I made a million
dollars a week a milon a week back way
back in the in the in in the '90s
1990s when when when you got to that
level I guess what I'm trying to say is
when you got to the level of the number
one did you all of a sudden be be like
man I don't know why am I creating new
enemies when new people are getting
pissed where older people being woken up
because they were jealous and envious of
how you know where you went and how is
she she's not better than me how can she
be there I did you start seeing that
other people targeting you or no you
were free you were flying you were
having a blast nobody was getting the
away of your success I was always on a
we weird uh W wavelength of my own you
know but yeah I did start seeing that I
start seeing Oh my God they've
completely isolated me and I don't have
anybody to talk to I don't trust nobody
around me that's and things are
disappearing out of my house you know is
weird oh wow and it was like being a
prisoner like when I think of those uh I
mean I don't mean to compare myself to
that but you know when them when those
girls got held in that house for 10
years in I can't in Ohio yeah it was
kind of like that and you couldn't say
anything because they were all hooked up
together like Kanye says you know your
trainer was all hooked up and they were
all hooked up together and their job was
to control you and to only you know make
sure you only saw the things that were
beneficial to them that you only knew of
the things that were beneficial to them
and by beneficial I mean that their pay
would increase who did you trust at that
time like nobody literally nobody I
trusted nobody wait a minute no family
no agent no uhuh I had already my family
had imploded by that time and we didn't
speak for many years so I didn't have
any allies really that's a tough and I
was like I'm going to have to get myself
out of this and how am I going to do it
and I did do it but you know I had all
these plans that I was going to uh
change my identity and disappear because
I I thought they're going to kill me so
but I want to say that when it first
happened the thing that was so great cuz
I always admired Elvis you know loved
Elvis and uh part of my fantasy of
getting famous and Rich and all that was
I was going to want to be like Elvis you
know where you would like really I love
that show the millionaire too where
you'd go and help people CU you were in
finally in a position to put your
beliefs into practice and you could
actually help people and so that was uh
a a l a large part of what carried me
through in the beginning cuz I was like
oh man I'm going be able to do this I'm
going be able to start uh these
organizations and my thing was about
children you know Abus children and and
so I did I did so much of that and I I
did a lot for uh you know various things
like that and things that were important
to me I could underwrite and that was
really that was just a great feeling cuz
I was like uh that's what you're doing
it for you know you know years ago
and also I love to I love to fund
lawsuits that was the hugest coolest
part of the whole deal literally yeah
for real why because I just was on this
thing for justice you know and I was
like oh hell yeah I'll pay for that
lawsuit what type of lawsuits do youing
I took some I did a lot of lawsuits I
did one lawsuit before I was even famous
that went to the Supreme Court and we
won I didn't find that out for 15 years
that we had W but what was the case it
it was about uh nonprofit
organizations and that's a whole other
story but um yeah uh whether they can
use the
word revolution or
reform so that that's a whole long thing
rosan when when you're
uh but like mostly women who had been
slighted in work and especially like for
the uh hostile work environment oh I
love that one love funding lawsuits yeah
it was a blast that's pretty interesting
I do I funded one on on a an Indian
Reservation too to be able to uh
legalize their ability to grow uh
cannabis and we won that right you know
I just wanted to
be I just wanted to uh I wanted to make
God proud of me you know that was what I
really wanted
cuz I was like yeah you know store up
your Treasures in Heaven you know since
what age three since three yeah what
happened at
three
um I
just I had like a big Spiritual
Awakening I I don't know if you call it
Awakening but an experience at three
that like set my tone for the rest of my
life that I've never gone astray from
about just doing you know I I wrote
about it in a book I wrote a book called
Rose
Anarchy and uh I talk about my personal
relationship with God in that book and
how God was my uh you know all kids have
uh uh an imaginary friend when and mine
was God but it really was and I would
always talk to God and uh and uh he
would answer and everything but in the
book I say that I'd
say why don't you fix things I'd say
uh all you have to do is move one of
your fingers and you could solve all the
world's problems and that God answers me
goes I don't have fingers Rosanne but
you
do and uh he said and you should you
should really be glad that I gave you
the opposable thumb so it can really
help you to do do things in the world
and uh you know those are the kind of
conversations I had but I grew up in an
apartment house with Hol cost survivors
in Salt Lake City Utah that my
grandparents had sponsored over from
camps and uh
so I heard horror stories from the age
of you know before I could
even probably walk and uh and at age
three I just felt a presence and it told
me that I was going to live and that I
was going to
tell and uh you know I did and I I did
how how chaotic was your life at three
well it's terribly chaotic in in what
way well you know uh every Friday night
these people would come to my grandma's
house and we'd have Shabbat dinner and
um my Grandma had a window sill and I
would get up there and entertain because
you know I was a big show off and um my
family lied to me and told me I was
better than Shirley Temple and I really
believed them till I was about 12 and
then I was so angry when I found out
that they were Liars but uh they were
partially true though I mean you were
number one you became number one think
about it like I guess yeah but I I
really thought I was doing the Good Ship
Lollipop song and dance better than
Shirley but yeah but I did get him to
laugh and I got him to uh applaud and I
I just was turned on by that that I
could take some miserable people and
make them happy for a little while and
that made me feel so strong and so good
and that is what I do but uh also shake
them up a little bit you know to go hey
wait a minute maybe it's not the way you
look at it maybe it's something else and
I love doing that I I've loved doing
that with comedy always and uh you know
but I uh you know they would tell
stories about what they'd lived through
and they um or also watching the ikeman
trial on tv and they'd make me watch it
you know and oh God the horror the
horror pictures and stuff yeah and then
they'd talk about what they had been
through and I was like I thought that we
lived that way still I thought it was
the Warsaw Ghetto in there I thought we
were still there and uh you know it was
a lot of trauma and I I grew up with a
lot of trauma and my family uh the men
in my family they were kind of working
class and my dad was a football player
and they were kind of
violent you
know but uh and the women were violent
too you know you know you you had to
really be funny to keep from getting hit
in my family have to be funny to keep
from getting hit yeah if you made them
laugh then they wouldn't hit you that's
a pretty high standard for comedy what a
tough what a tough rule you better that
joke better be good they're laughing
they're not hitting yeah so I I kind of
learned to tell jokes and my dad was
real funny too he wanted to be a comic
he kind of made me one and uh so I
always had comedy and
uh and uh I loved it because I thought
oh boy that's the only place you can
tell the truth about anything and I
loved that in history the the comic the
fool the uh Jester could go was the one
that once a year could go into the king
and tell him tell jokes about the King
to his face and he'd have to laugh cuz
all the people were watching and that
was what made him beloved to the people
cuz he had a sense of humor about
himself like Don Rickles would go in
front of Reagan and just crap on
everybody yeah but yeah that was what a
job what' you do today I just made fun
of the president I went fun of rean and
crapped on everybody in his whole
cabinet by way I know I know I know it's
it's a weird time for us to do you know
I wanted to spend a lot of time just
talking about you and learning more
about your background Maybe we'll do
that in the second half of the podcast
but with everything that's going on
right now in Israel I'm sure you have
thoughts on that what are your thoughts
on what's going on there with Hamas and
Israel well I haven't stopped thinking
about it since it happened there's so
many weird things to it uh first of all
of course I'm always praying for all
children of the world uh who are
innocent and harm and In Harm's Way on
every Side of Everything uh I I just
think maybe were on our way to a more
sane World sometime soon where people do
consider the innocence of children and
uh and that hopefully would make them
more intelligent and more
uh more human that they'd be guided by
that rather than you know this kind of
primitive get even thing which I hope is
leaving and um I hope that's going in
the past but I I feel bad for all the
all all of the innoc ENT victims of my
people my family lives there a lot of my
family and
uh it's just terrifying it's terrifying
historically and uh geographically and
politically and in every way and uh and
then when you really break it down and
look look at the facts of
it it doesn't add up which ones oh the
whole thing doesn't add up um so you
have to
go what is this really and who benefits
from this right you always have to ask
those
questions but it is weird that Israel
which is like has such high technology
for all all this uh warning warning
signs you know a what do you call it
their defense their defense is is is
top-notch billions and billions we even
give them billions and billions each
year the the world's best none of it was
antip none of it was functioning well
they got
through and then they went all the way
back without one alarm sounding MH well
according to the Wall Street Journal
this I too have family there I was just
there um a few months ago I took my
mother for her first time in 30 years by
the way my mom says hi Rosanne big F oh
nice um say hi back I will she'll
probably watching this smiling right now
but talked about family there I was just
there I saw the protests that were going
on on the ground they're protesting
against BB
Netanyahu uh sort of a trump-like figure
you know famous political he's been
around forever
um but the the in in one capacity they
think that they took their eyes off the
ball lesson that can be learned here in
America today while you're creating
divis divisiveness internally there's
always someone externally willing to
attack you thank God that we have the
Atlantic and the Pacific that way when
their own infrastructure didn't work
well here so what does that mean that
means and I've been trying to say this
to Jewish people for 100 years
uh and to Americans and to everybody you
know there's an enemy Within and I think
we all know that and what are we going
to do about it uh you
can't ignore it and you know you look at
Israel and everything that's going on
there and they have basically the same
problem that we have here in America uh
people
who
um hate the place they live they hate
the government that they live under so
you know I think that you know like a
lot of people say e Egypt warned them 3
to 5 days ahead that it was coming and
they did did nothing so what does it
really mean was it allowed was it like
Pearl Harbor where uh they say that our
president knew that it was going to
happen but you know to do nothing was
more expedient than to do something
because doing something might have made
it
worse but
um you know then you have to look at the
fact that I thought it was weird I don't
know if we can talk about this on your
show but that the that that those uh
vaccines were tested on Jewish people in
Israel and you know is this a captive
population that the owners of the world
think they can use as labrats again and
again and again even in their own State
I mean is it that big is it that
horrible and I kind of think yeah it is
and I think that the people that were
protesting for judicial reform is just
like when they overturned Ro v Wade here
because it was a law created by judicial
Fiat which is anything but American when
a bunch of Judges decide what the law is
going to be the the laws are supposed to
be made by people who who elect
legislators to pass those laws but
instead that law was created by judges
and that isn't how our country works
that was a beginning of the overthrow of
our of our country I think and the same
was in Israel people were upset that
there
uh leftwing judges were creating law
there and they they were sick of it and
so the way the American Press covers it
is that uh you know it was a right-wing
blah blah but it wasn't it was a
people's and they always seem to frame
anything that comes from the people as a
right-wing thing populist yeah they
don't like populism for sure but you
know I think that a lot of people who
were I I've been to Israel you know and
a lot of people there
are like the left here they're very
privileged they're very like those
educated people I talked about before
they're very arrogant and they're very
privileged and they don't care about
people you know on the ground or do the
real work that makes things go they have
nothing but contempt for them and
because they're not
they
elitist and I think that that was a a
lot of a lot of that too so I think
about why did it happen and what does it
all mean and of course then I get really
upset too
because that was my tweet that I got
fired over the Valerie Jared tweet yeah
that that they Unleashed you know
everybody I don't you know liberals
think that Planet of the Apes I guess
they think it's a movie about black
people because they are that racist but
it's it was actually Rod sirling himself
who wrote it said it was a uh movie
about the German Holocaust of Jews the
beginning of it and so they I knew that
that Iran deal that Obama and Jarrett
had authored was to unleash Planet of
the Apes in Israel and it and it did and
that's exactly what happened and the
ultimate end of it that they desire is a
military lock down state and I think
they did it there to test it to bring it
here and do it here next CU you saw all
those people that were out in every
major blue City that were you know
celebrating what happened to Jewish
people you know they were flying
Palestinian flags and uh Pro Hamas we
have Hamas in our Congress but um
yeah when you look at ilhan
Omar they have they have the Palestinian
flag outside her office with her with
her door closed can you pull that up Rob
well the point that I was trying to make
to you is like how could this happen how
could this happen well how did it happen
that we uh are allowing people say that
a lot of people that are coming across
our border are
Hamas and those kind of people they are
coming the middle of course I do what
percentage of people you think
cross I'll tell you right now rosan not
to cut you off 160
Watch Terror watch suspects were caught
at the US Mexican border in 2023 caught
and I talked to Pat this how many out of
the what seven eight million that came
over and mind you this administration's
attitude is come in come in come in come
in now this happens you think these
people M and I heard this rosan I'm
pretty sure you did too that the UN un
the Biden Administration has given these
18 to 24 year old war AG fighting men
single they're not coming over here with
families give them my cards they give
them this money thing where they're like
Hey listen we'll keep replenishing the
money here's a cell phone if we need you
we're going to call you what what what
are they doing so there's and you nailed
it Rosanne there's two things that
happened with this with this attack
either a they knew and they did nothing
or the intelligence it was just failed
again either way somebody has to be held
accountable cuz we have to figure out
what the hell's going on I think I think
we have to go who's who's who
benefits the most so
you think about it who do you
think
well we're
done we're done in congress with uh
talking about Joe Biden and the Ukraine
right I think that's all been exposed
but they were just starting to go with
what did Joe Biden do in China what did
not just Joe Biden but all the crime
families in DC uh you know all
the all the political prostitutes that
say they're representatives and Senators
what deals did they make with China and
um
perhaps what happened there was part of
the plan of the owners of the world uh
to distract from that I think the people
that
ultimately uh gain the most from it are
um the people
are
China and uh the people in DC who are
fighting and have been fighting since
Trump was elected to keep their crimes
out of the news to keep the American
people unaware and uneducated and Ill
informed of the criminal Enterprises
they've run against the people and the
people's money so you know they've taken
public money and put it into private
pockets that's what Congress is and
nothing more so those are the
two main beneficiaries I see of this and
also it seems as if
Iran is as who backed this who backed
Hamas they have it was a suicide mission
ultimately
because it's not going to stand Israel's
going to go in there house to house so
they knew they said I feel like Iran
sacrificed
Hamas because sacrificed yeah I think
that was a sacrifice of Hamas because
while the world's looking there uh
looking at Israel going into Gaza and
the whole thing here comes hez
Bola and that that's a big that's from
the Lebanon side mm that's going to
while everybody's looking here that's
going to come here so it's like and
they're going to get him in a vice and I
just
think the longer Israel waits to
retaliate the better it's going to be
because I think things will come uh more
broadly
into understanding and I don't think
that they should do it reflexively I
think they should wait and I was glad to
see they should wait what do you mean
they're already attacking Gaza they're
trying to get their hostages uh what do
you mean weight I think that's a limited
strike mhm cuz they have a lot of men
but I was glad that they are doing a
kind of a surgical limited strike there
to get the hostages back well if you
take BB by his word he said that they
are at War now yeah I he's a person that
he's an interesting person and the
things he does are interesting because
he talks big but then at the end he
always gives up land for peace every
time did you notice
that has Natan yahu given up land what
the Golan Heights what what area did he
give up he always gives up
settlements well they're called but
they're actually neighborhoods and he
makes the Jews move out of them he does
that well that was way more under Ariel
Chiron and even Ehud Barack way more
than than but that's the whole
conversation in Israel is the people on
the left say listen we need to negotiate
with these people you know we need to
succumb to some of their demands the
people on the right yeah but Netanyahu
is not on the left he's on the right
he's basically saying we can't negotiate
with these people as the famous say you
cannot negotiate with terrorists so what
happened you just gave $6 billion do to
Iran to pull out five hostages where do
you think that money went probably right
to Hamas probably right to Hezbollah so
you know I was starting the frame of the
conversation with why' this happen how
did this happen well sometimes when you
take your eye off the ball you know you
missed what's right in front of your
face so Israel uh technological
Powerhouse arguably the strongest Air
Force and Military in the Middle East
intelligence and intelligence of course
the Mad there's the according to the
Wall Street Journal they were focused on
the wrong War why they're so focused on
cyber security they're focused on
intelligence their focus on air power
they focus on Tech where they completely
just missed the ball it's like yeah
there's going to get some freaking
bulldozers and some paragliders and just
come in and start slaughtering innocent
victims well that's they on 911 it was
box cutters brought up exactly exactly
but is the the biggest question is this
isra question I think it is
but a bigger question is why didn't all
that infrastructure work was it hacked
nobody ever nobody saying that how do
you hack a wall well well I'm talking
about the technological infrastructure
yeah because no because go well you we
don't know what you're saying is Adam
and from from a from a security
standpoint I get it there could be stuff
happening inside your country and people
are fighting that does not diminish the
security apparatus that is set up there
is absolutely no excuse for going well
we're worried about the voting thing and
then cuz dude think about it the Iron
Dome and all that stuff everything is
set up basically to Perfection so I know
what she and they also said that the
victim said that the the the police and
the military didn't arrive for 6 to8
hours after it went down yeah and by the
way I've seen multiple multiple videos
of IDF and Israeli intelligence people
saying there's 0% chance that they
didn't know this this is not me saying
it these are people on the ground live
in front of a camera saying zero chance
that with our security we had no idea
this is coming so that's the thing what
does that mean well that that's that I'm
telling you they allowed it to happen I
don't Adam listen Pearl Harbor gave us
justification to get into World War II
91 911 gave us justification to start
the illegal war in the Middle East and
expand them uh military industrial
complex it's like they I don't know who
who's who knows because it's like how
many intelligence failures are going to
happen but it it's obvious that they
they want every place under military
lockdown they want all free societies
that go that way yep everywhere but I'm
worried because it seems like Israel is
the point of the spere the spear for
America too it's our it's our uh you
know point of the spear in the Middle
East and people want to pretend that it
isn't but it is it's very Americanized
there in in a in many ways but I'm
afraid you know that it's like a preview
for our country well just to be clear
I'm not necessarily I'm not denying or
confirming these sort of allegations of
what what we but let's State the facts
the facts is Israel is the nicest house
in a rough neighborhood okay very true
so you know would you rather be the
nicest house in a shitty neighborhood or
the worst house in a beautiful
neighborhood I'll take the lad if you
look at Israel okay this economic
Miracle that's happened since 75 years
three people in Israel live you know on
government assistance okay so they were
founded on on social well they the kabut
lifestyle we get that but when you talk
about democracy we talking about people
having an ability to vote and vote for
the you go ahead move to Iran Rosanne no
go ahead move to Syria let me know how
life is in Lebanon go ahead go to Gaza
and be a loudmouthed woman there let me
know how that works out for you you're
dead I'm not saying so like the moral
equivalency is absurd to me so you're
the you're the worst H you're the nicest
house in a shitty neighborhood what are
you supposed to do Israel you know the
they want peace and you know what so
does Hamas the only difference is they
want a piece of you over here and they
want to blow everything up the moral
equivalency to me is insane Israel will
will will before they attack Hamas they
will literally do what's called a roof
knock on a on a on a building and say
we're about to blow this building up cuz
a missile just came from here you have
10 minutes everyone to get the hell out
of here do you think that they're giving
heads up H you think Hamas is giving
heads up when they're going to kill ter
kill innocent people why are you making
it sound like I support I'm not saying
that you're that you're supporting Hamas
but the moral told people to leave they
already told get out cuz we're coming
but the problem is Hamas is embedded in
hospitals in schools in houses and they
will shoot from those areas and say
shoot us back so we can have the footage
of babies dying and women and children
the only difference is Israel's
literally trying to avoid that why just
like the United States is because well
you know why we actually value human
life they do not value human life how do
we know this they actually will provide
suicide bombers to accomplish their
mission they do not value life to about
that because I hear this all the time
and I don't disagree but I'm going to
tell you why they're like that because
of the ngos that pay them it's called
pay for
slay and it's for Jewish blood and it
comes from the left and these leftist
NOS a lot of them out of Germany a lot
of them out of Switzerland a lot of them
out of Holland they pay for sleigh and
those people have no jobs they have you
know no hope and the only way they can
make money is to join Hamas and be in a
a bully gang that not only does what
they do to try to kill Jews to get paid
mhm and if they die their family gets
paid but they also bully all of the
Palestinian people around them too and
when people went in there and asked the
Palestinian people where would you what
who would you where would you rather
live in Israel or under Hamas the
majority of them said they'd rather live
in Israel so you are uh This what I want
to say they are a paid gang mhm and it's
like you know the cartels in Mexico that
cut people's heads off and stuff like
that they are not representative of the
people they're paid by Nazi I call it
Nazi NGS they're very they're Jew haters
and they're paid by
leftists a lot of it is American leftist
a lot of whom are quote unquote Jewish I
tried to go to up in Marin County to
talk to them to confront them up there
about why are you paying for uh you know
anti-Semitism and death for your own
people why are you contributing to these
causes and you know that was the first
time I was ever deplatformed but that
needs to be
said and a lot of those people in Israel
uh they were I call them Obama Jews and
he spent a lot of our us tax dollars
there for for people who are communists
and don't like Israel the number one
thing of Communists is that they hate
Judaism they hate Jews who practice it
they hate the Bible they hate God they
don't believe nothing and that's a lot
of who uh was part of the tearing apart
of the social structure in Israel as and
the result of which was when Israel's
last election not one leftist was
elected uh to the knesset not one
because they finally got it and
hopefully America will get it too when
you're paying for pay for slay as we do
here in America too with antifa and BLM
that's pay for slay to burn down cities
from from you know a left a communist
takeover of our country that's what
you're going to get so I I hope they do
I I was shocked that Hamas would commit
suicide like that
but you know that's the only way they're
going to get paid a series of funding
agencies have existed over the decades
including fund for families of Martyrs
and the injured the fund is often
referred as the Martyr fund and uh
pejoratively as pay for sles it's $300
million by the way wow uh to fund this I
think this is very important that you
point out because it is coming from
certain factions on the left whether you
look at the George Soros contingency or
the squad or the AOC whoever the
sympathizers on that end but at the same
time it is also coming from the number
one uh regime of Terror in the world
which is Iran at the end of the day we
could say all right well you know it's
coming from the left and certain people
are supporting this but who fun this is
all Iran but who's funding that who who
just sent him $6 billion you're
precisely right this is why you cannot
negotiate with terrorists well and that
we've learned the hard way that people
on the left no let's try to work this
out Obama and his apology tour going
around how can we do this let's fund the
nuclear deal in Iran and let's let's
figure this out let's give them a
hundred billion do we have the people on
the right with the Trump Camp being like
like you can give them $10 million you
can give them hundred billion they're
still going to try to kill you
yeah like that's not going to stop so do
you want to fund the death or do we want
to actually choke off this money so it's
coming from all sides but to be clear it
is Iran number one that's the funer of
terrorism and and Rosanne I well it's
not the people there either uh the
people are really rebelling against all
of that they're rebelling against the
Jarrett uh which people Obama the
Iranian people well exactly the
politicians not the leaders the people
because they know what's about to happen
I mean you can go speak for days about
this they know what's so here's a
parties involved here right let's look
at the parties involved we got Hamas we
got Hezbollah we got obviously Iran
funding it there was reports about the
fact that Hamas has been training a
thousand soldiers on they built a city
identical to a city in Israel and
trained on how to break in and how to go
in and take the hostages and Brak them
and they're like what are we training
for we can't tell you what we're
training for we're just preparing in
case something happens and then all of a
sudden okay here's what we're training
for we're attacking Israel so then you
have Saudi Arabia is also involved in
this Iran's involved in this then you
got potentially Russia involved in this
China involved in this and US involved
in this there's a lot of parties
involved in even Egypt right now nyaho
saying hey if you're living in Hamas go
if you're living in uh Gaza Gaza go to
Egypt just to make sure you're safe but
Iran you think the Iranian people are
sitting there wanting to see this happen
dude all of a sudden the targets hearing
Nikki Haley screaming off the top of our
lungs we have to attack you all these
guys screaming we have to do this so
they saying we don't support this but
this could go zero to World War III in
in seconds by the way just to say this I
wanted to say when I was in Israel
something really miraculous happened I
was uh I was there and our people I was
with our phones rang I we I don't know
how this happened but our phones rang
and it was people from Iran were calling
us I don't know how they got our phone
numbers or anything and they just said
we want you hi we're calling you from
Iran and we want you to know that we
love Israel and we love the Jewish
people we are calling you to let you
know that we don't go along with our
government and um it was just I still
all my hairs are standing remembering
and and I knew then I knew
that something even bigger
than every government on this Earth
every compromised government something
even bigger than that happening between
people and uh that's what I hold on to
and hope for for all the children of
this world I think something really big
and good is going to happen is happening
and uh and uh I I want to increase that
I I know that in Iran
uh I I hope this isn't offensive to
anybody but the people are
uh on a Grassroots level I know they are
really becoming
um they are becoming very well they're
converting to
Christianity like crazy like they are in
China too and so they're becoming like
more
westernized and also Muslim people are
becoming
less
fundamentalist so all these things are
happening also and so maybe the owners
of the world don't like that so much so
they have to stir the pot to keep people
divided and hateful towards each
other I always say it will be such a
great day when all the hate we feel for
each other if just for one moment we
could take all that hate and channel it
upward to the people who are at fault
who cause it all instead of each other I
think that's I think something smart is
happening in all of us and and that is
happening I don't know if it'll take a
hundred years or maybe even a blink of
an eye but uh I I feel that that's
happening too and you know maybe maybe
God won't let the world blow up I don't
disagree and and you know 3 four weeks
ago I had a couple Muslims here and I
had a couple Christians here and they
debated and they had a discussion
together we're going to do many more of
these and it was he yeah it was
obviously heated but it was at the end
of the day we're sitting there saying
hey we kind of have a lot of the similar
beliefs when it comes on to certain
things of course we're different in five
areas but in these eight areas we're on
the same page I don't disag important
that's the most important thing and
we're going to be do doing many many
more of those just to have the
discussion of course I posted something
on uh uh Twitter and Instagram the I
cannot believe you said this Pat I
cannot believe you did this listen guys
what do you expect my support to be I
was born in Iran I saw what happened
when I heard thousand I still have you
every time I hear I saw the video
yesterday after they got the $6 billion
Iran screaming at their you know if you
can pull this up mad bad om mad bad om
death upon America after they got the
money they're saying death upon America
that's what we're funding we're funding
a country that hates you America and
you're sitting there saying well it's
not a big deal right there look at this
you know screaming off the top of their
long Mar B on uh uh and that's in
Parliament what is that yeah this is
parli can you get audio or no yeah go
for it right there that's good
just you know how many times I've heard
this in Iran when I lived there 10 years
mad B arm so but but but the point is
you're seeing this is going on and you
know what what do you think position I'm
going to take I'm I'm America I'm
America I'm going to be this where my
kids are you think I'm going to sit
there and defend a different no but do I
sit there and watch that father who's
walking around with his holding his
Palestinian his dead daughter walking
around am I emotional watching it hell
yeah I am of course I feel the pain as
well but to me I don't support this
Behavior I don't care what side it's
coming from I don't support this
Behavior you know as as much as weird as
this was rosan I want to get your
thoughts on this I was having this
conversation with my trainer this
morning he says he Pat you know people
are asking what does Pat think about
what's going on in this or you haven't
done an emergency podcast I said I
thought we did a podcast on Saturday we
talked about this with Timol and Jimmy
but
I said you know what's weird you know
how sometimes you have a leader that
sometimes it's rough around the edges
you know he does his job he drives the
hell out of you he kicks your ass he
maybe it's a head coach a CEO president
just kind of like hey expects more from
you what a what an you know why
can't he be a little but then guess what
Nobody messes with you and your family
Nobody messes with your company nobody
comes to Target because they know holy
we got a guy like that there when
Trump was the president love him or hate
him man guess what we had BLM riots we
had protesting going on in America
nothing around the world people were
worried about what he was going to do
and there was nothing Isis was every day
under Obama we heard we feared Isis
Trump one word of Isis boom gone
how boom gone what the number two number
what do this could be before yeah boom
gone you know Tel Aviv to you know uh uh
Jerusalem boom hey no nothing's going
hey Ukraine Russ Afghan no nothing boom
Biden comes in okay it's all about peace
it's all about peace it's all about
peace Afghanistan leaves the equipment
behind that Hamas is currently using
Russia invades Ukraine under you you
fund them nearly hundred billion of our
money that we given to them then all of
a sudden we're seeing what's going on
with Israel and Hamas right now most
people dying nearly a thousand people
have that I believe 11 Americans that
are there hundreds being held hostage
big biggest for 50 years this is going
on in Israel taking place and the
effects in America gas prices are 729
right now people are having a hard time
making their car payments they can't buy
a house right now rent a skyrocketing
and what happened but we have no BLM
rights in America we have no none of
that stuff going on in
America it's so interesting right
nothing mean tweets by the way you know
what's crazy for me is the average
person who you know when you vote you
have to your vote M cuz you you look
like an idiot if you don't okay you have
to know why you're voting of course but
what I'm saying is like after you voted
and you're amongst your peers you're
like and you win and you're like oh
this was a pretty but still look at the
amount of awards how amazing of a man he
is and all this stuff Jamie Diamond last
week talked about the fact that he
thinks AI is going to cause people to
work three and a half days a week well
guess what folks if you want to work
four days a week if you want to work
work 3 days a week if you want to work 9
to 11:30 a.m. a 2 and 1/2 hour shift
during the time this is taking place in
Israel well guess what go be a president
because Joe Biden took the day off after
11:30 yesterday a.m. yeah and on Sunday
guess what they had at the White House
wonderful barbecue yeah can you imagine
what the barbecue is are let's talk
about the conversations hey would you
like some mustard on this think you're
great so what do you think about all the
stuff that's going on can I have another
one are you kidding me like what is this
the Optics
I think it was like oh boy they're not
going to they're not they're not going
to find out about us yet we're going to
push this timeline off we're going to
start as many wars as we can and as many
places as we can so they don't find out
people are figuring it out but I think
people like us were asking the questions
and we're like what the hell is going on
you know yeah listen I wanted to give
the guy a chance of saying okay I I
actually want to like you and I want you
to succeed as a president and I'm hoping
you create peace great I'm hoping not
only do we get peace in the streets not
only do we get peace around the world we
don't have to worry about wars and all
this stuff happening let's see let's
give you a shot maybe we're wrong maybe
he's the right guy but then guess what a
lot of people are saying no we were
right this guy's not our leader look
what's going on in America in every
possible way Galla pole is saying that
they trust Republicans for the first
time it's a 14-point flip from Democrats
to Republicans 53 favor you know
Republicans running the economy to 39
more favor Republicans running the
military for protection then Democrats
we haven't had these numbers for decades
yeah so maybe something is really
happened in America that we're not aware
of maybe something is going on around
the world it's kind of like let's pump
the brakes because it's so much High
throttle right now the level of chaos
where all of a sudden you know how
you're at a bar and you're like like
you've been at these fights or bars
where you're like what you say
it's like hey Johnny don't
worry about it no and then you see a guy
going over there start and all of a
sudden he goes and calls and goes he's
going outside what's he going outside
you like do let me go outside see where
this guy's going he's going to the B
opens the trunk grabs something puts in
the car oh this so hey Bob don't do
that bro put that back in the car
let's get out of here you don't want to
do this right now dude let's just get
out let's just say he's one of your guys
we got to get out here you're not doing
this right now bro that guy's not going
to talk to my girl like that totally get
it we ain't going to jail get your ass
in the car it's when that hits here
you're just trying to diffuse and leave
the bar I think we're there right now
and a lot of people are like dude if
that guy goes in there takes that thing
out of the trunk comes inside then who
gets hit who knows so there's a part of
uncertainty right now where I'm talking
to guys in in in but you got to read the
signs look
look okay go over this with me okay you
see all
these Hamas supporters in the blue
cities thousands hundreds of thousands
right here we had a protesting down the
street mhm New York Sydney London they
made themselves I'm just talking about
America okay okay cuz this where we live
you know uh uh they made themselves
visible so they that that's a military
move okay they didn't they just didn't
come out for no reason this is the most
ironic thing I've ever seen quer for
Palestine go ahead go ahead go ahead do
that March in Gaza you're dead that's
the irony well
was the places that well I won't go into
that but yeah get on into it Rosanne
well we need you I was going to say make
your first point first was the prot
depending on what Israel does to
retaliate or to in self-defense you know
it's retaliation for you know the
invasion they were
invaded
um if they anything they do is going to
draw
uh condemnation from from those people
right anything even you defend yourself
if you do defend yourself there and give
out cookies that somebody's going to
hate that you know but uh I think it's
it's
uh it's going to cause uh something to
happen here well that's my concern so my
concern is going to that bar situation
the guy's grabbing a gun and another
person is saying dude you should beat
them all he can't talk to you like that
we're doing that more than saying dude
let's get the hell out get everybody in
the car let's get the hell out of here
you know I talked to a guy that was a
bodyguard for president I said so what's
your job if somebody tries to kill me he
says my job is not I said how good of a
fighter are you he says dude I'm not
that's not my job I I said so how are
you trained when somebody tries to
attack the president he says our job is
to get the hell out as soon as possible
our job is not to fight fighting takes
time and people can retaliate and they
can kill you my job is to get you the
hell out of whatever location we're at
right think about the training of
somebody that thinks that way in that
situation today in America we're more
sitting there and saying yeah they said
that this is not fair what about this
and you shouldn't do this is getting
people's level of agitation to go high
and this is what a great instigator does
to create a good boxing match but in a
UFC fight but that's in a freaking ring
nobody gets killed it's between two
people you cannot take that philosophy
and apply to politics that's where
tensions are super high and I feel we
have that today in America can you
notice though can you notice
that the
way those people the pro Hamas people
look so similar to antifa I mean they're
not wearing masks here but look similar
to the people who burned our cities down
a year and a half ago did you put those
two wires together uh I think that they
are
planning some big stuff here in our
country against you're saying for
election pre-election oh I was just
going to say think think about the
timing Roseanne I don't think there will
be an election I've said that but uh
yeah I think I think it's going to be
well think think about the chaos think
about the timing Pat this is election
year right we're how many months away
Pat months okay let's this is this is no
coincidence P check this out we're one
year away from an election okay look
just look rosan what is this left and
I'm tired of them just going well the
left wide openen border okay Trump's
motto was what peace to strength we have
zero strength The Border's wide open
econom is in shambles we are energy
independent everybody's fighting you
just nailed it it's complete chaos we
have no idea who the hell they let
through this border every time but
mayorcas that little rat was in Congress
and they're asking him direct questions
is are we secure as the board of secure
he'd say we do a fantastic job zero
answerers so for people that act like oh
it's just Joe Biden just they're dumb no
no no it's all set up because I'm
telling you right now rosan the goal is
what Pat not to let people go and vote
the fear is going to be something that
these thousands of people that we just
let in that are on this Terror watch
list that we don't know watch the chaos
that's going to cause in the next 14
months watch I think that they're
telling us ex they're they're telling us
what they want to happen is that you
know who who's the threat to all those
people it's uh the white supremacists so
break that down who who are those people
going to be looking for exactly and it's
a setup it's a setup against Trump
supporters and people who watched my
show and uh you know the workingclass
America and they don't like black people
either when they say white supremacist
they always include black people who uh
you know are working class that's who
they mean they mean any work it's a
class war and they put fancier names on
it but that's all it is by the way check
this out so you know how the whole thing
was about how dared this man want to
build a wall and do this and do that and
now Biden wants to build a wall Weir and
on top of that here's what Arnold said
yesterday Arnold schwarzeneger calls for
impassable border on The View demands
reform to stupid immigration system
Arnold Former Republic expressed his
views on immigration crisis EMP in the
need for compr imigration reform he
stated I believe very strongly and
having a border that no one can get
through additionally he called for the
issuance of visas of foreign workers
stating we need the workers here Schwarz
criticized the existing immigration and
label it as stupid and then he urged
bipartisan cooperation to address issues
saying why can't we come together
Democrats and Republicans oh yeah Mr
Arnold schwarzen screw your freedom
screw your freedom Mr Arnold you screw
your freedom why do you want to have a
border huh didn't you say this 3 years
ago to the people that wanted a freedom
now you want to come and act like you're
a unifier you divided two years ago
you're now a unifier Mr Arnold yeah I
know you got a book out and you're
trying and he said Trump was pretty much
he pretty much called Trump a racist for
wanting to build a woman yeah you know
this is a guy it's so disturbing for me
the reason why it's disturbing for me
because coming up as a kid this is a guy
I looked up to a lot I went to Santa
Monica Community College cuz this guy
went there I wanted to be a bodybuilder
cuz this guy did there he was a
bodybuilder the greatest uh bodybuilder
many would say and you have the American
dream go become a governor you marry a
Kennedy and then all of a sudden you
become a rhino all of a sudden you
become this you know well you know I
don't know H this this that just because
you Tred to do apprentice and you
followed up and you failed and he was
able to get to certain levels you
couldn't do now you want to now you're
saying border matters yeah so look it's
okay to change a position but you have
to say I was wrong before you change a
position never say they were wrong they
never I think we should be able to say
you know what we told you so how many
now we're not say I told you so I and I
also want to say you owe me an apology
you fired me and stole my life's work
cuz I told the truth and what I said
happened so you can all kiss my ass
Disney and all you mfers kiss my ass I
was right unfortunately but what did you
expect when you censored everybody who
was critical at all in any way of of the
Obama Jarett Administration and their
Iran policy how dare you you sent
answered anybody who was critical at in
any way of that and look what you got
but by the way truly though look what
you got you know certain you ruin
certain people's lives you now
fortunately in your case you have money
you're okay financially right but you're
creative you're Talent you you you
survive by doing the talent that God
gave you which is perform and make
people laugh that's why God put you on
this planet right and your show coming
back doing what he was doing but imagine
the other people that they got silenced
and they don't have the voice they're
not going around able to express
themselves they're forgotten they're the
Forgotten Bunch that are you know small
little show small little not I'm not
going to let them be forgotten because
the I felt like what they did to me they
was doing to my audience and my audience
left ABC and my audience I also got uh a
letter saying we saved up as a family to
go to Disney Land and we're not going
cuz what they did to you and uh you know
like I say in my act you know they
killed my character and my character uh
cuz they was calling me a racist the
next day at ABC on all the news uh even
though I told them I thought she was
white in the picture that I captioned
she she doesn't look you know anyway I
thought she was white in the picture but
anyway I say in my ACT but you know
watching
Disney theme par par s be empty because
people can't afford to go there anymore
and watching their woke movies bomb like
Russia in Don
bass uh I I say I ain't the one that's
dead
you well speaking of your show and
getting cancelled right so they canceled
the only number one show they've ever
had right so this is I guess my my point
my question you know they say the in in
the old media days when the central time
zone
right win the Midwest like that's really
what the core audience is so for for the
younger people out there I don't think
you guys fully understand how big of a
star Roseanne was in the 90s late 80s
early 90s was when Roseanne really took
off we have like 40 million a week yeah
but you know it it was you and Madonna
arguably in the 90s and the skit that
you guys did Linda Richmond on SNL with
Mike my Barb Sten I mean classic
so that show at the time even though it
was number one wasn't at a time where it
was as divisive as it is today and when
you rebooted the show in what 2018 I
want to say 17 okay so 2017 2018 and
they decided to cancel you for a tweet
whether it was wrong or wrong they
canceled you but where I want to
go with this question is that show they
didn't cancel none of the pedophiles at
their Network that were caught all that
same we I think they used me to cover
that up they used that News St to cover
me but let's say you were still air this
is my question Rosanne I'd be dead but
you I feel like that show would be so
important for America today why there's
you're in the midwest you're in Chicago
I believe your sister was a raging
feminist you adopted a black child you
had a lesbian in there like you're a
trump fan and there's wasn't adopted she
was my son's daughter okay so even
better but you have all these Dynamics
going on in this household that is that
is emblematic of what's going on in the
United States was overheard in my
writer's room cuz people would spy to me
cuz it was me against them you know 25
liards in the writer room and uh
they it was just un unspeakable but
somebody heard when I wasn't in there
that uh one of the writers goes I'm just
afraid she's trying to humanize Trump
voters with this show so that tells
you that tells you what an insult to the
viewers that pissed me off really bad I
love what you told Kimmel though I love
what you told Kimmel what when he won a
show with with John John
Goodman oh the Democrats went so far off
the cliff you said still the same my
shit's still the same 100% I don't like
and you know they just cling on
to it like it's for real like it's for
real and you know there was two rosan
they keep using the word Trump I we are
we are past the Trump thing it's what
the guy stood for and let everybody wake
up and see just just cuz you support you
know what it is I feel like because you
guys know I don't know if you know but I
ran for president in 2012 and I ran as a
representative of the black caucus of
the green party which the green
party didn't even know they had a black
caucus cuz they left us so racist which
is why I left the left because of their
racism so it's ironic that they called
me a racist when I did did everything I
did was to integrate my my crew my
writer's room against them fighting
against that all the time those people
are the ones call me racist okay well
you too but anyway
um uh I forgot what I was saying about
the GRE the the you went to the black
caucus for the green oh yeah yeah so uh
eventually their racism that was so
because I had a black I had black people
Nation of Islam a black woman and a
Muslim woman as my uh team and they
would get them against the wall these
leftist white people silver ponytailed
marxists I call them and they would be
screaming in their faces about how they
weren't the right kind of black Muslim
or a Nation of Islam white people doing
that I was sickened by it but that is
who they are and I think that they hate
Trump uh my friend Cynthia Kenny she
said Trump won 2016 and 2020 he won big
and he won black and that's why they're
panicked that's the real reason why
they're panicked because so many black
people particularly black men saw the
scam of the Democrat Party with their
poverty programs which is taking public
money putting it in private Pockets it
never gets to the people when you go in
any like this particularly Nancy
Pelosi's district is full of homeless
black people on the streets dying living
in and she go she's calling Trump a
racist and he went in there and I
believe that his economic policies
included some form of reparations which
was bringing Economic Development to
those blue cities and he did do that and
boy they hated him and they hat him
because he gave the middle class tax cut
and I just interviewed a Democratic
candidate and she said I wish the
Democrats would have done that and we
could have taken credit for that and I
go yeah but you never would do that well
you've been involved politically for
decades now you said the in 2012 and
then and eventually Jill Stein went on
to be the candidate you saw that Carrie
Lake just came out and said that Trump
should consider you as a potential
running mate she did yeah I don't know
if you saw that I didn't see that I love
her though there you go oh my God
congratulations Rosanne you're the
freaking BP now baby well I said in 2012
when you you know I didn't win if in
case anybody knows but I said I
president bar I declare myself the def
facto president of Americans Inc I made
the whole thing Americans Incorporated
because I knew they was going to
bankrupt the whole uh DC
Incorporated which what's her name Dr
Jan helper said that's defun Joe Biden
is the president of a defunct
Corporation that's
broke and so I declared my myself in
2012 the de facto president of the
American people for life but today I
want to say I when I ran in 2012 I was
saying that I was a twofer president of
the United States as well as prime
minister of Israel so today I'm saying
I'm declaring myself de facto prime
minister of Israel too okay well it's
fun to be delusional okay it's not
delusional if I say it it's not
delusional so it's your truth not the
truth she can identify whoever I have my
truth and I'm going to tell it and like
Trump borrowed a lot of my campaign
ideas from 2012 which I say he's more
than welcome what ideas did Trump steal
from you I said audit the Federal
Reserve okay and that is what he did and
moved all the money to the treasury a
lot of things I said a populism not
democrat or republican neither of them
there a duopolistic fundraising arm of
the uh military Pharma industrial
complex
so we need another party that cares
about the people and it's the same for
Israel because Israel tries so hard to
be American so you know I think it's the
51st state and a lot of Americans do too
even though they don't call it that but
anything that happens there comes here
no doubt and and I'm afraid of that and
I don't want to see that happen I want I
want the Constitutional public of the
United the constitutional republic of
the United States of America long may it
wave I'm proud to be a citizen here and
I'll do I will do anything within my
power and my power is only about raising
my voice I guess and telling jokes and
like that and talking to people but
I will continue to do it until I am
removed from this planet because I want
to encourage other people to do it too
go talk to other people go pray with
other people people that don't think
like you that's how we're going to
change everything is speak to other with
some dignity uh don't try to be smarter
than or talk down to people like the
left does just listen absorb let's solve
some problems let's respect each other
and let's come up with something new
that actually works and and then let's
all get all these religions together
which I do when I go to Israel I always
pray with Christians and Muslims and me
women we all grandmothers we all pray
together for the well-being of the
children of this world that we can rise
above the and take care of the
kids that's a grandmother's prayer and I
have said it for uh 20 years now in
Israel with all these women of uh
various religions and then we dance
together and I'll tell you what we do
change the we do change the revolution
of this earth when we express joy and
love with each other and a faith that is
far above anything negative and hateful
that that's everything to me I love that
my vote respect respect rosan what do
you think about the RFK announcing he's
running as independent oh I think that's
so smart you know because they wouldn't
they wouldn't let him you know they
they'll Bernie they'll burn they already
Bernie sander him but uh I think it's
good I think that all this shakeup all
this new way of thinking any anything
that comes Against The Establishment
which is what we're living in now this
establishment uh anything that comes
against it and Shakes up rocks the boat
is just going to it's great and uh it
gets people thinking the worst thing
they did the establishment was that
quarantine the worst thing they did to
themselves because it broke people's
routine and mind control is dependent on
routine so they're so stupid luckily for
us thinkers that they put us all in a
thing that broke the routine and
therefore broke our mind control and
that was a beautiful fresh new day for
America and the more they keep trying to
do it and breaking our routine the more
free thought we're going to give birth
to so I really think we're on the verge
of something wonderful and good even
though it looks
terribly negative right now I I think
keep the vision and uh keep the faith I
think it's coming I think so as well I
think we're finding each other here's
what a sister said on Twitter yesterday
you can zoom in a little bit Rob
regarding what R this is about RFK
running go up to the zoom go up to the
first tweet at the top uh yeah so Bobby
mik shared the same name as our father
but he does not share the same values
Vision or judgment today's announcement
is deeply saddening for us we denounce
his candidacy what a scumback and
believe it to be perilous for our
country statement on Robert Kennedy Jr's
announcement today the decision of our
brothers Bobby resur on third party
candid against Joe Biden is dangerous to
our country Bobby might share the same
name as our father but he does not share
the same value so we denounce Rory
Kennedy Carrie Kennedy Joseph Kennedy
second and then you have the last one
that's Townsen and I responded to this
and I said what you say I said can you
go to my tweet Rob they're part of the
establishment can you go to right Rob
can you find I have it it's just locked
up there okay there you go this makes oh
that's great you said this I said this
makes me want to support him even more
it's unfortunate to hear both your
father and Uncle were doing everything
they could to fight The Establishment
and they paid for it with their lives
here here and their policies are favored
also favored more of today's Independent
party than the Democratic here here I
love that you said that thank you so
much can you imagine your your sister
and them just literally on you
for the establishment shame on you well
shame on that who is this Rob Riner what
did he say Bobby Ken J and dangerous and
cynical move by wealthy Republicans to
put Trump back in the White House I
talked with Bobby and told him that what
he was doing is destroy American
democracy he didn't care riner's a
freaking
running for president will destroy
America and they didn't care about your
opinion not understand that you're very
smart man that's crazy he should
immediately drop out as you know
democracy is dangerous to our democracy
and we can't let Americans
vote that's crazy well that would be
fascism let me ask you guys this and
this is coming from a genuine place of
of respect where given the Trump Biden
uh do opol I would definitely consider
voting for B K I really would 100% um
but a does his family know more about
him than the rest of us just general
question and number two and this is I
think the more important question is who
does his third party candidacy affect
more does it affect the Trump base more
does the Trump candidacy or does it
affect the Biden candidacy because we
saw the numbers come out what a week ago
we talked about it I think Saturday like
50% of Republicans approve of RFK where
it's like
15% of Democrats go ask the question and
I want you to answer it if you're asking
it what what what context in this
discussion does it have if his family
knows him better than the rest of us
know him of course they know him better
than the rest of his know what's your
point with that well you maybe they know
something we don't he going do something
radical like like what like what well I
don't know that's why I'm not his family
I don't know but if your entire family
it wouldn't it be a little bit weird if
the entire osana family came out and
said yeah we don't recommend Vinnie or
the BET David family or the bar I don't
you know what that would tell me you
know what that would tell that would
tell me that family is political party
over family yeah that's what it would
tell me and it is it if my kids ever did
that do you know what I would do to
Dylan too sen or Brooklyn if they ever
publicly chose that over their own
family you have no idea how annoyed how
disappointing this behavior is to
publicly say something like this simple
you can simply say we have differences
but we wish them all the best okay we we
have differences but we wish him all the
best and that's the right approach to
take now to answer the second question
which party you think RFK is going to
hurt more Republican or Democratic Party
by running as an indep like will he be a
Ras perole and hurt senior or will he be
a Ras pero and hurt maybe Biden in this
situation well I think that the the way
I look at it is that they were uh
polling Democrats and young Democrats
like
RFK young Democrats like
RFK yeah young Democrats and by the way
you know there's an article that came
out yesterday very truthful on you know
he's truthful on stuff that the the
Democrat Party uh is um wanting to sweep
under the rug well did you see what
Trump had to say about RFK and this
might be our answer well here's the
story says team Trump readies attacks on
RFK as spoil anxiety grows this is page
12 because a lot of people are saying
what if it's a trump RFK uh what do you
call it VP team Trump is preparing to
Target RFK internal campaign polling
suggest his third party bid could draw
more votes from Trump than Biden in
general election One Source stated that
the polling showed Kennedy taking more
votes from Trump than left-wing
independent coronell Westwood from Biden
if both protested to counter his
Potential Threat Trump's campaign and
allies are planning to release
opposition research on Kennedy with one
source saying we're going to be dropping
Napal after Napal on his head reminding
the public of his very liberal views
dating back to 2012 the research aims to
highlight Kennedy's past statements
including comparing Factory meat
integrators to Osama Bin Laden and
labeling the NRA a terror group well
that would be good if Trump did that
because that'll make more Democrats vote
for RFK won't it I I I don't know if
there's a large contingency within the
Democratic party to vote for RFK the
numbers don't back it up in in fact B
why would Trump want to attack RFK
because he knows that there's a way
larger contingency on the right that is
listening to RFK especially the
libertarian vot if he says that he's a
liberal and brings out all rfk's liberal
policies then nobody on the right is
going to vote for
him what are his liberal policies I
don't think he seems to Liberal he just
said his things about a terror group and
meet Osama Bin Laden nobody on the
right's going to vote for that it just
still boggles my mind can you pull up uh
if if Biden is going to be the guy
Biden rosan is going to be the guys how
can you in your right mind as a democ I
don't give a damn about party over
whatever how can you in your right mind
vote because he's the front runner am I
Am I who Biden of course how the hell
for the Democrat yeah 100% how can you
in your right mind vote for that are you
you you'd be out of your mind but that's
the exact question yeah just so we're
super super super clear brother that's
the exact question the people on the
left are asking about Trump
yeah how in the hell can you vote for
that so just to be clear sorry but mine
is both sides are asking that question
understand but mine isn't off
personality mine is look at what the
hell happened in this past four hold on
look what happened in this past four
years and I said that we told you so how
can you in your right mind say from
Trump was just the mean guy I can't
believe he said this look at the
country's State of Affairs right now
that's my point I I know what you mean
like how could you vote for Trump but we
were right we were right about a lot
well polls are anyway so think
about it people vote their pocketbook
and they're really going to vote at this
time because look at gas is what seven
in New York and Cali there was a $7 how
much was it pat pat $7 $729 in certain
areas people are going to vote if they
do get to vote I don't think we're going
to have any election you really don't
think we're going to get election no
they're not going to let us vote what do
you think is going to be the stopping
Rosanne what are you saying right nowan
what do you mean there's not going to be
an what do you think it would be I
understand hyperbole I understand comedy
I
understand being funny and I'm not being
hyperbolic I'm being I think there's
just no way they're going to let it
happen why well because we didn't fix
the that happened in
2020 for one thing okay all all of the
things that
happened uh so if they're who when you
say that're they're not going to allow
an election run a poll do people believe
there will be an election or no just run
a poll and see what they see goad it's
growing all the time that people saying
there this is just all theater it's just
all theater by the way just so you know
she's not alone there is a lot of people
there A lot of people that think there's
not going to be they'll suspend it
either for war or what pmic too I'm not
going to say what but there's a lot of
differing opinions of what is going to
happen by the you know in the next year
or by the end of this year okay what
what can you use in United States
history that that proves they will they
will not be an election has there ever
been not an election every four years
has it ever happened in US history even
during coid I'm actually genu question
there's something in our history but I
can't bring it up I'd have to I had it
but I I have to relook it up there was
yeah what I I heard something that
there's a way that they could suspend an
election if something is so is happening
where I'm curious well if you didn't
suspend it in uh 2020 why would you
suspend it in 2024 I just don't I've
never heard this Theory I'm not saying
that it doesn't exist I just don't know
how that would be implemented it does
exist say if uh the 2020 election is
declared
fraudulent and then what happens you
tell me if what say that again if the
2020 election is declared
fraudulent by
who by either the Supreme Court Congress
I don't know some the military I don't
know have there I mean there's been no
rulings in that regard so um look under
Cog continuation of government look that
up okay let's check it out Cog but so
you're you're how certain are you that
there will not be an
election I I wouldn't be surprised if
there wasn't okay but I don't see how
there can be when we the uh you know all
of the uh things that went wrong in 2020
mhm I don't think people have confidence
enough to vote I think a lot of people
won't even bother
well that's definite fear well well let
me tell you this if if we okay so let's
let's uh let's play a game called
hypothetical okay hypothetic let's play
the game let's say people vote because
they think their vote matters if people
don't think their vote matters they're
not going to vote like what happened in
Georgia when Trump told people not to go
out and vote you can't trust the voting
and then they inv voted two Democratic
senators how does that work out telling
people not to vote telling people that
there's fraud telling people that you
can't trust the system telling people
that it's rigged does that inspire
people to vote no it lowers turnout and
that what that's what happens like
Georgia as an example which was 50/50
could have gone either way Trump
basically suppressed the vote you get
two Democratic senators there warock and
Joel ostein or whatever the hell his
name is not oin but but the the point is
like suppressing voting telling people
that your vote doesn't matter saying
that it's all rigged that doesn't
benefit showing people that their vote
doesn't matter on video is also
something that affects them what video
the video of them bringing out suitcases
of votes remember that some of that was
proven completely some of it but there's
I mean you saw the the movie with Des
duza it happens a lot it happens a lot
it just was it just was uh the
signatures har Lake just won in Arizona
that the signatures were all fraudulent
so you know we don't know what's going
to happen Carri Lake won in uh KY Lake
signatures were fraudulent she won yeah
she was just here last week no her stuff
her lawsuit about the S you know the way
they Lo didn't have complete custody of
the signatures and the signatures didn't
match she won that I I don't know if she
did because she came here a couple weeks
ago on the podcast and she said she's
running so car Lake's third trial to
begin after unsuccessful loss
challenging her loss in 2022 Governor
this was like a couple weeks ago no it's
not that because I just had her on my
show and we talked about it but I have
to go she she announced that she's
running for Senate is what she announced
but for the governor deal they're not
willing to the the part was they're not
willing to verify the signatures what
was the case Rob that they were not
willing to do uh ver show the signatures
of the voters to verify the legitimacy
of it that's what was the challenge was
they didn't want to do that they're like
no we feel that's a risk to do something
like that but let's play but she did get
a judgment that they I I have to look it
up let's let's let's go with this
concept of there won't be an election
but go to continuity of government cuz I
think that answers everything that one
has to do with nuclear war I believe the
continuity of government if you want to
go to it zoom in a little bit uh um
actually go there's a go to the
Wikipedia side that just explains to you
what it is a little lower you'll see
right there two down there you go zoom
in so continuity of government is a
principal establishing Define procedures
that allow a government to continue its
essential operations in case of a
catastrophic events such as a nuclear
war uh continuity government was
deployed developed by the British
government before and during World War
to counter threat such as that of uh LOF
what is that word what does it say in
the US Cog is no long longer limited to
nuclear emergencies the Contin operation
plan was activated 911 so by the way
this is what I'm saying if we go to
hypotheticals okay say hits the fan
right now Ukraine Russia you know
Hamas People Israel say just something
happens there and it leads to an allout
war and then somebody pulls the trigger
yeah launches the nuke somebody does
okay then God forbid 1 million per God
forbid all of a sudden the next 6 to 12
months you know how much Mayhem is going
to be everywhere shutting down curfews
oh yeah you think they would let that
crisis go they would never let that if
there's one thing about Democrats versus
Republicans they have mastered the art
of not letting any crisis go to that's
right that's why I'm saying that's I'm
bringing it all back that's why I'm
saying about these people on the street
that look like you know they they look
like the people they look familiar to
the people we've already seen burn
cities down so just say maybe Israel is
is a catalyst to them to attack uh
Americans who who they see as the enemy
white supremacists whatever the the the
characters that are being introduced
into the theater on of uh media look how
that is a crucible moment that could
occur and if it did explode in like
Civil War in American cities then there
wouldn't be an election would there NOP
this is you know what this is stry this
this year leading up is turning into uh
season five episode three of House of
Cards where the president is like he's
knew he was going to lose and all of a
sudden there's just fake you know let's
say that there's something happening
here there's a terrorist thing happening
here it's not so far-fetched what she's
saying especially when we don't know
where the hell these people are that are
just hate America that are just running
around this country waiting for
something bad to happen it seems like
it's a lot of cells a lot of cells of
people that we're just not even looking
at it's right in front of our face and
we're just ignoring it and watching the
Kardashians asses but um hey hey you
know it's like it's like things seem to
be moving into place and we're being
told things and things it seems like
they're set up for something really
really
big and uh so that's why I say I don't
know what they're going to do here but
but you feel something's coming I feel
like it's kind of orchestrated and it
keeps the heat off the the people that
uh these investigations are getting
closer to uh yeah you know bringing to
light and of course the media doesn't
cover anything but there's something
horrible in the fact that our president
sold
access to him to
China I mean hello and isn't it crazy
Rosanne like you made a great Point
since this whole thing is happening with
Israel everybody forgot about Hunter
Ukraine the Speaker of the House drama
economy everything is i' haven't heard
one peep Trump were everybody was
talking about Trump everything is off
the nobody gives a about anything
except there's one problem and also
think about like everybody's eyes on
Israel over here well what does that
what's going to happen in
Taiwan right did you hear what VC had to
say about that he said you know you talk
about you voting with your pocketbook
and you know as James carel famously
said it's the economy stupid uh China
stupid he said it's China stupid and you
know what happened Ukraine everything
going on in Ukraine everything that's
going on with the Border everything
that's potentially happening with Israel
now all this is it just a distraction to
what the big the big game is
I think and and uh you know they don't
like America the big globalist owners
they don't like a country that has a a
constitution that guarantees individual
rights what the hell they think that's
so obsolete they hate that they like a
docel Workforce yeah and then obviously
we know that if you want to go down that
rabbit hole you know where does Iran get
its money other than the hostage money
that we give them is from China how many
billions of dollars was it $50 billion
was it some crazy number oh it's way
more 400 billion over 2 400 billion
sorry I was way off there 400 billion
over 25 years over 25 years gotcha I'm
thinking of like what their first
initial payment was but right there
right there look at that China with $400
billion Iran deal yeah but at the end of
the day alliances are being formed right
so if you look at the alliances between
China Russia Iran Iran North Korea it's
like you want to be on that team or do
you want to be the United States the EU
Israel Canada Australia it's like time
to pick teams it might like end up being
something we don't even expect though
that's why I'm always thinking Jes this
could go a whole different way that we
have never even thought about that's how
they throw you that's how they uh
distract you yeah you know what I don't
understand you always hear like you know
you're going to push Putin into she's
arms you're going to put it's like well
it's kind of like if your girlfriend is
cheating on you or if already has that
dude's number there's nothing you're
going to do what are we going to do to
to bring Putin back into the fold like
if he wants to team up with China it's G
to haveen I I'm sure there's going to be
some diplomatic answer that uh
completely just usurps what my opinion
is but like the whole premise that we're
going to push Putin away into China's
arms they're literally bordering
neighbors it's not like they don't have
each other's contact information if
Putin and she wanted to form some
Alliance uh they're gonna do it so I
don't understand that premise I I don't
know what's GNA happen I just I hope
we're I hope we
uh come out a better world than we are
now Rosen you know bring it into your
industry so you know in the political
world world you're like well uh uh I
don't know who's behind it the people
that are behind it you know some people
will say well every war was financed by
Bankers all the way back to rotchild to
UK to this to Colonial everything's been
financed by Bankers so it's a Bankers
War right yeah industri military
industrial complex no it's the bigger
guys the Koch brothers they choosing no
it's the Soros no it's this in Hollywood
you know the the people that look at it
from the outside they
say wow you know these guys must have
been you know great on how to make it up
and I remember I was working with this
one guy at B and super good-looking guy
65 blue eyes white guy all this stuff
and I'm spending time with him and all
of a sudden one day we go partying with
this guy realize how he made his money
which was crazy but he used to be in
Hollywood and he says one day he gets
invited to a party with uh David gin's
house and he's doing work he's doing
movies he say we're about to make
it so him and his best friend go over
there they're both good-looking guys in
their 20s and I say David wants you
upstairs in his room so they go to his
room and David's like this is the story
he's telling me now whether there's
truth to this or not this guy didn't
seem like he needs to a story
like this but he says so David says hey
you guys I got a movie I want to put you
guys in great yeah but I need you to
please him right in front of me and this
guy's like what yeah I need and his
friends like dude I'm down if you're
down dude I want to get a job in a movie
he like hell no I'm out so he left he
left the industry I'm done with it for
us from the outside watching in and you
hear stories like uh Weinstein or you
hear stories of gfin you hear stories
about these guys how how dark was it
back in the days in Hollywood and how
much of this was happening how'd you get
past it for a person that wanted to come
up and compete you know cuz in politics
you have to do favors to find a way to
go up right the favors could be
different kind of favors that you do how
dirty was it and how much of that has
changed today within Hollywood well I
never for some reason well I always say
it's because nobody ever wanted to
me that's not true Roseanne that's not
true I'll will take you down right now
that's Rosanne test me well you
don't have no power in Hollywood so
that's what you think steep in my office
we're going to get to your own show baby
girl I'm talking about you know them so
I didn't have to you know I don't put it
past me rosan I'm just letting you know
right now legendary story that would be
right that left a million years ago
but uh
uh I
didn't that didn't have nothing to do
with me I didn't have to I used to have
good joke about it that I say you know
what who do well it's not it won't work
here but uh no I didn't have to do that
I say uh I was uh one of the few that
made it on
talent but uh no I uh I love her uh but
no I didn't get none of that happened to
me but I knew people that it did happen
to and because I was working uh to uh
help
kids uh kids who were you know in
slavery and from drugs and sex and stuff
in Hollywood they had run away to be
stars and you that's what happened to
them they'd get mixed up like that and
be used uh I heard their stories and I
knew it was common and I knew that uh
it's just a den of iniquity and uh I
heard from people that you know
everybody knew somebody who had to do
that kind of deal but especially it
seemed to be in the movies and the uh
music but
TV I didn't I don't know it probably
went on but I I didn't I had to bully my
way on the TV though but they didn't
want me at all what do you mean by bully
well they didn't want to do a show with
me in it did they try to recast you like
rosan who's they the networks oh okay
got it they didn't they yeah they were
like I remember the day I was shooting
my pilot my sister was there and there
was she said she was standing next to
all my agents and the producers of the
show and they didn't know if she was my
sister of course I always have a plant
see good good and uh uh she says she she
says that they go who's going to watch
this show about too f F people too fat
and allowed this and that she told me
wow yeah how they R old yeah but then
you know I knock Cosby off yeah and then
you know I but I knew I knew American
people wanted to see themselves not
degraded and they wanted to see
theirselves portrayed as kind of heroic
cuz I did when I was watch TV coming up
but uh you know I had to force it and
they uh then they had to eat my dust
good and they didn't like doing that
neither and they they never liked it but
I'd be like you know I I relished it I
mean I have to say as was a high school
dropout telling them people from Harvard
oh it was a joy it really was a joy
rosan who who was somebody you met that
was kind of like you know when you're
making it you're then you're like number
one and you're making a million million
a week who was who was the celebrity you
met for the first time like that's kind
of cool like I'm having dinner with XYZ
I'm you know I'm
having all my Idols I mean that was the
most amazing thing uh well I mean I
could name them off it I forget
everybody's name but uh number uh I
can't even say number one but as a comic
to meet all my comic idols and hang out
with them and have a few drinks and
smoke a joint and you know Jam jokes
with I I got to meet Richard prior I got
to meet and hang with Dick Gregory who
was
a God you know a God and he ran for
president on the same ticket I ran on
and that's why I ran because a Dick
Gregory but uh uh you know Phyllis
Diller was a friend Joan Rivers Rodney
Dangerfield he left me his pot in his
will oh W I got his pipe and his
marijuana and for did you smoke it or
did you keep it no I didn't dare smoke
it I got it in my office that's great
yeah and uh you you know oh God I'm
forgetting everybody what about George
Carlin yeah I loved him too met him
rosan did was um he's a gen oh yeah he
was everything he said I was just going
to say it right now it seems like this
is sort of like what you're heart right
now we're world like people he's like if
you're Brown you like the bomb brown
people he's like if you're Brown you
better watch the FL he was the best oh
he was funny to the end what do you
think of Comedy today you like if you
look at SNL you were on SNL was in what
you did with Madonna and Barbara strien
that's a fun show if you can stay up
late it's live at 1:00 a.m. but is it
still funny in your mind no it's not
funny has what about late night Kimmel
Fallon Co bear what's your take on all
that the the late night comedy scene
Greg goldfeld is the number one yeah on
TV he's funny I think he's funny and I
think his I think he's a Trailblazer I
like this show it's number one
interesting oh is he number one cuz he's
actually just normal and everyone else
gone insane on the left because he's the
least funniest person out of all those
people I just named you think Gutfeld I
think you think he's funnier like I
think
his oh well Jimmy Fallon is really funny
but I think the team around him it keeps
it snappy and going I think he's got a
whole new way of doing late night and I
think it it is better because it's like
boom boom this person's a it's a lot of
standup so it keeps it fresh so I think
think it's a new format that really
works I think the I think the white guy
behind the desk bored y you know like oh
like I mean I don't know about you guys
but nothing to me screams Brilliance and
comedy than like Steven coar and they're
dancing as needles and telling people to
get the vaccine now that is brilliant
they're like get the VAC get a needle I
don't know if you they were doing dances
I a choreograph thing and it's like it I
I think it's just all that like like
Johnny Carson all those guys David
Letterman after those guys it's just
like nobody wants to this is this is
what comedy that is what comedy it's the
death of comedy and all these shows are
disgusting and I I I it's I can't cannot
watch these type of shows they should
use this when we catch terrorists and we
want to find out information from them
they should tie them up Rosanne and play
this and be like tell us where your
leader is and that's what they got to
show them it's horrible that was that
was the death of Comedy that's it that
was it it was but you know they have to
do what the CIA tells them to do or they
wouldn't be allowed on TV 100% right you
saying the CIA yeah well unpack that CAA
is the CIA CIA oh the creative artist
you're saying is the CIA they get the
same talking points at 4:00 a.m. you
will you will say Biden's a genius and
to take the shot you will you know you
think so you think that happens you
think I know it does you know it does I
know it does I know the
lgbtq plus BS I call it that movement
are the BS new letters in there that's
coming
from um yeah they're all they're all
connected there they're all like uh you
know the
establishment even even within the
talent management area the the ca is
telling the talent what to say what not
to see CIA is CAA they're the same thing
that guy work they're all operative
of keeping in the narrative so they
can take over I mean they already have
when you Cable's getting crushed right
now right I mean if you look at what's
going on with cable there's an article
that came out and it deserves to be
crushed too because it sucks check this
out story came out saying well will 2024
election uh save TV political at spent
for Joe Biden Donald Trump rematch will
likely find broadcaster and cable
swimming in cash Okay so Trump won't do
it Trump won't do what now he ain't
going to debate Biden you don't think
Trump's going to debate Biden hell no
why not
cuz he's not stupid what what do you
mean by that Trump ain't stupid enough
to De to debate Biden again because
Biden's such a formidable opponent
because all he does is lie because all
Biden does is lie yeah so why would he
do that you know what I would do if I
was him what this is what I would do I
would say before I debate Trump by
I would say I want to get
everybody on Twitter to follow XYZ
account our person's going to fact check
every time Biden says anything retweet
it for the world to see it every time
during the debate that's what I would do
if I was Trump and fact checked it
instantly within seconds on Twitter and
share it on Instagram Facebook you know
Tik Tok put it everywhere instantly if
he's going to do it that would be way to
do it yeah that would be the way and
he's got the camp to be able to do
something like that well that would be
cool he'd probably put it on Truth
social though he but but his other camps
his son's always tweeting so his you
know there's other people that are part
of his Network that would put it on
Twitter and he would need to be tweeting
during election I think Trump is a I
think and I'm going to see him in a few
days but I'm telling you this he is when
I do see him I'm going to bow down to
him and I'm going to go you are the
master showman you are Barnum and Bailey
times 1 million you're the master
showman and I think he's going to wrap
it all up and it's going to have a great
epilogue this show he's going to wrap it
all up with a real nice bow and a really
great epilogue you think he's going to
win oh yeah I love so there's not going
to be election but if there is you think
he's going to win well I
think if there is an election yeah he'll
defin but there's not going to be an
election we know that I I said I
wouldn't be surprised if there wasn't
and I don't think there will be because
I think something else is going to
happen and can I ask one question
Rosanne if we're being hypothetical if
there is and I mean from the right I
mean V and all these guys we see that
there's no chance Trump is is is a whole
different message and well a lot of us
think that he's still commanderin-chief
100% that yeah so ran you think Trump is
the current commander of Chief and chief
of the United States of America
currently yes I do okay what evidence do
you have of that um a whole bunch of
uh executive orders from
2015 I'll share it with you okay so
then then all the stuff that's happened
the the withdrawal from Afghanistan the
inflation the high prices the Consumer
Price Index is that now Trump's fault no
I told you Joe Biden is the president of
a defunct Corporation in DC he's causing
all that okay so what is Trump doing
since he's still the commander-in-chief
in all this he's the commanderin-chief
of uh
the constitutional republic of the
United States of America and I think
they're two different things and I'll
show what are his
rules
he I would that's too long of a
conversation but I'll show you I'll show
you all the stuff I have on it this is I
I don't know this world I generally
don't no it's from Dr Jan Halper Hayes
who works for the Department of Defense
look her up she says it uh so so Rosa my
question was going to be if there is and
we obviously it's obvious with the
numbers Trump is going to be number one
who do you think cuz everybody's saying
that there's no way that the left is
going to have Biden cuz he's unvote and
he's old and who do you think would be
the person to slip in there well they
say they're going to put Michelle Obama
in I I heard that as well yeah did you
hear that I heard I heard that or new
some there's all this stuff even though
he announced it's like you never know
what these people because I mean and
Michelle was the Roger Stone said it a
while ago he's like I'm telling you guys
right now take it to the bank Michelle
Obama's going to be the savior because
she's like listen he's too old we can't
do this Trump is oh my God I hope they
put Michelle up because I have the best
Michelle Obama jokes they killed
last I I was really afraid to do them
but they killed so I hope they do
because I just have great Melle you so
the rumors all because I mean as we saw
just really fast f so we saw Larry
Sinclair on Tucker exposed you know put
put Trump you know all the allegations
about Trump and smoking crack and
cocaine and you mean Obama Obama Obama
with uh Larry Sinclair yeah yeah yeah so
he exposed that they've been silent you
know Obama was dead silent Michelle
Obama apparent still overseas on
vacation she was seen in a yacht with
Tom Hanks of all people random do you
think that like there's so many rumors
about him even Joan Rivers said it and
she passed away two weeks later do you
think there's any validity about them
him you know his relationship her being
I mean you hear this all the time
everybody the Internet calls Michelle
Obama Michael I know they do but like I
say these are my jokes yeah cuz she's
the one that got me fired you know
Michelle yeah she's the one that called
uh ABC and said I had to go my racist
tweet yeah really yeah is this public
information I've said it Michelle she
said it it's got be true it is too I'm
GNA smack you right acrush your
face well I I I applaud you on when
you're right but when you say things
like Donald Trump is still the president
and there's not going to be an election
I said commander and chief I respect the
hell out of you when you say things like
that change everything I'm not changing
anything commander-in-chief now
listen
uh Bob Iger who fired me said his first
phone call was to Valerie Jarrett to
apologize to her and that Michelle Obama
also got on the phone with them and that
Obama called him afterward to thank him
for firing me so that's in the paper I
didn't make it I believe you I didn't
make it up that's something that sounds
very incredible iger's many interviews
where he talked about it but yeah she it
was her she called for me to lose my
show and be fired so of course I've got
a Jones out on her you know you have the
right to and I said uh you know I have a
lot of jokes but I wouldn't say them on
here because that would be wrong oh you
can give us you can give us
one a lot of people say think Michelle
is a man I don't I think she's a woman
cuz only a woman can be that big of a
for one thing well played
and um I never said a word when she was
serving fried turds to kids for the
school lunches I never said anything
about that because I'm
nice
um Rosanne who's your you know Pat's
coming out with a book it's called
choose your enemies wisely it's coming
out in December oh good so I'm sure
he'll send you a copy who would you say
your number one enemy is today great
question Satan good okay because that's
what is the real deal no human we don't
none of us got a human
enemy we don't the enemy is the evil
inclination inside of each of us we have
to fight there that's where the war is
won and lost Rosanne you're amazing
appreciate you for coming out you have a
podcast for the folks that are watching
you have a show Rob let's make sure we
put the links to all of it in the chat
in the description where's the stand up
show where's the standup show you're
next I don't know oh you don't know yet
somewhere Melbourne uh at the end of the
week then clear water as well so to
rosan bar.com so much you're so amazing
Rob you're a cutie thank you rob thank
you guys it was fun sitting here with
you and you're getting a smack Jewish
grandmother right across mom is going to
be so happy on my
viewers be a new pilot you're going to
get slapped in the face by Rosen I
actually want it gang have a great day
Rosanne thank you we'll do it again this
week take care bye-bye bye bye thank you
so much get security Rosanne you're
incredible